we're gonna give me some flan my huh you
guys ready yeah I love start with mom
Angie here this is mama Angie well I
think I met her before can you tell us a
little bit about her day
mama Angie is she loves working out
going to flea markets and she can squat
630 pounds
how much is that Brenda she can ask what
will she say 630 pounds so she said 6:30
maybe if she's on those khabib pills man
no sorry I'm she looks like she's on
them [ __ ] cookie pills
uh-uh she's swole bro she's also pushing
her body very hard up in one direction
yeah very directional she's bigger guns
than both of us though I love her hands
she has the hands you see on like a lot
of those prayer videos you know at
church go sumin just on the hands look
if you ever see like on those videos of
like donation and prayer and stuff at
church like happy heart or whatever or
you know the happy heart congregation on
the sign they have it looks like you
guys black tattoo of praying hands yeah
so yeah every stripper going back to you
house yeah every outdoor stripper from
Denver she looks like a bricklayer look
at those hands I'll lay that brick baby
damn oh you could build a dang vestibule
around me if she wanted I think she's
beautiful man let's zoom out on her a
little bit
I listen out if I was in a foxhole I'd
want her big ass around that's no way to
[ __ ] get to her heart bro what do you
mean like if I was in a foxhole I'd have
your big ass around
first of all foxes hide what the [ __ ] do
you even know about foxes dude not a lot
but in the foxhole what I'm saying bro
if shits going down I'm gonna be I feel
protected around her she looks like she
might be in the on the SWAT team she
squats 630 pounds she clearly knows we
get illegal steroids there's a lot going
on here oh yeah here's a biohazard
tattoo so she likes to jam is that what
that is yeah it's biohazard zoom in on
that that could be anything could be a
boat propeller it also looks like it may
be some off on the back of a yah it
could be a BMW sign too yeah it could be
something that she got when she was at
Coachella yeah it could be also a Jimmy
Buffett one of those right that might
not be biohazard like I'm sticking tats
but I'll say this beautiful body
very nice definition look at the Clavis
do you could eat soup out of those
[ __ ] son yeah I'm full rack of ribs
up top there oh yeah and she has that
full she got that neck oh she's got that
neck that crater bro
oh dude sniff all the coca you know like
neck it like neck it Ralph boy let's get
naked
you know nectarine is just take our
scars off and get straight [ __ ] neck
itch she looks like a bad [ __ ] she
looks like she just gets in her [ __ ]
old-school Oldsmobile
I just hits [ __ ] Godsmack she drives a
fine young chick around town do you
[ __ ] yeah and you go get them girl you
go get those young naive women out there
what's up you know what I'm saying that
after somebody's on me to market right
their brush she's running her own game
on the young lady she saying come get me
me too yeah get you some of this meat to
Rackham I'd let her spot me oh yeah the
only female I've ever seen that lets
spot me I'd let her spot me like a damn
Dalmatian dude I love her King Beck's
we got cousin Felicity this is cousin
Felicity damn well goddamn girl looks
like a nice spring day with some DSL Z's
so no name for other than his cousin
felicity she's a South African teacher
and the guy who submitted
said that he's had to beat up some guys
that broke her heart but she's done the
same to girls who have done the same to
him because they keep it gang gang he
also referred to his own cousin as an
absolute dime piece there may be some
going on there look man you know what I
say if you really you know cousins
you're good well you shouldn't have to
go far to [ __ ] that was the old motto
dude you know if you need gas money bro
then who you know do you really need to
know that person you know if you need
sugar you want to across the street yeah
that's your back rubbed you want to go
across the street yeah when you get on
the highway man and we start leaving the
family started you know step on a crack
break your mother's back once you get
out near the sidewalk I said keep it
local man
[ __ ] local look at a lot of these
different a lot of sects of humanity
they they keep it in the in the tribe in
the tribe look at the chimps they bang
their kind yeah chimps funny right
Tongans Hebrews they keep a lot of they
keep their a lot of their dating is
within their tribes Hawaiians Hawaii
they're forced to [ __ ] on the island
yeah think about that dude they're great
look how happy a Hawaiian is you've seen
a satellite know you've seen Moana do
where my sister yeah where my sister
lives people are related bro you throw a
frisbee and know into a field of no one
and someone will catch it that's [ __ ]
possibly related to you yeah it's that
kind of man birds start looking like
they shouldn't look like that you know
what I'm saying even birds know if you
don't flee don't fly far to [ __ ] know
like if flamingos yeah they're all the
same the mingoes do it yeah think about
that think about that I think a flamingo
we only have one blender sister
flamingo man I was just a powerful
substitute is she a substitute teacher
she's like a regular English teacher i
Regulus I would learn nothing but boners
if I was in that class yeah well I think
she seems like a nice lady I've learned
more than boners but I probably pay
attention and get a damn education dude
that's what it's why you had to go fight
for money for a [ __ ] decade that's a
legit but what I'm sorry man nah man I'm
being mean today I think I have a cold
that's why now it's your keto diet oh it
probably is dude dude I swear to god bro
I'll lick a [ __ ] did I'll do a line
of Splenda off a [ __ ] deceased baby's
back right now dawg oh my and that's
extreme so well maybe get off the diet
it's the dark arts no dude I'm trying to
look nice no you look nicer you look
normal
oh you looked exactly the same whether
they do it or not dude bro I can't even
hear right now okay so how would you
have to die my ABS coming but I can't
see your hair first of all is she's a
substitute teacher if she's dating
people you having a fight for why she
have on a wedding ring maybe that could
be yeah something's going on here yeah
maybe that's your wife dude and I'm not
mad at all King this girl all I say King
is she's beautiful she seems outgoing
she's out
words clearly nice yeah she's drinking
by a pond she obviously seems like a fun
person she has an accent a nice set of
eyebrows she's teaching people in South
Africa dude it's amazing drinks a lager
beautiful cut of beautiful country yeah
a log or hopping you know she's used to
having a couple lagers in her throat you
know what I'm saying
I like this what else you got Brendan is
that Paul Bunyan baby you know I'm not
Foster's down you're okay Wow his hats
getting tight
Brendan tight hats do Brendan takes a
hat off of like a baby like a little
doll that's in the room his son's room
like burnin this house would be a purse
and do the saloon bears how do that you
steal your mom's wigs so we're good yeah
only our show wigs you animal that makes
sense
last up this is uncle Bruce uncle Bruce
let's see this pervert oh my god Bruce
trying to [ __ ] alright
I think uncle Bruce is about to shoot a
porno that's what it looked like
[Laughter]
no bro bro he has to first of all he's
Filipino my he makes amazing Chinese
food
and he's looking for a nice white lady
to settle down with one day yeah well he
only has one leg that other thing that's
a dick you know he's one-legged brother
it's a dick down that other pant leg
look how it's a little leaner yeah boy
that [ __ ] one too meat stick Oh [ __ ]
Wow brother some [ __ ] Manny Pacquiao
you got that enchilada hitter in his
pants bro he's grilling meat on his
[ __ ] talked about a red talked about
that wet
rido I like this dude what's his name
again
Bruce Wow I don't I see sting can you
zoom him on our Polynesian friend please
ome should my ass well he's hiding his
face on to that hat
oh wow he's that very coy Filipino man
who do you think he's Filipino cat
that's a Filipino Wow and so what did
why did tell us more cuz if you know
more about Filipino men what's going on
here let's go live to the source well we
know he has giant calves true he's
clearly I feel like he god I love
Filipino men I'm just you but that's not
your thing
your boyfriend yeah I like him a little
chubbier though like Oh Joey a little
more pushing for the cushion you know oh
yeah you like you're a chubby chaser
well I don't like guys who are like fat
guys I like guys who can cuddle well I
like guys who can cuddle well if you're
ripped you're not fun to cuddle with
yeah I do nobody don't it's fun to cut
loose oh it looks like you wouldn't but
it looks like a snuggle the [ __ ] out of
you can looks like you're coming with a
panther yes i cuddling with a toaster so
coming with a [ __ ] crocodile yeah
uncle Miguel would be like cuddling
maybe or even throws it down is just an
epic color first of all the guy has been
dick piece in your back the guy has
2,000 trophies for being awesome his
[ __ ] one of those trophies for can you
zoom in on those d it looks like some
sort of dodgeball trophy or it looks
like he's running do the ladies their
jobs in all the balls if this dude's in
town bro can you zoom in on waiting
anymore
is that it oh you're running they say he
runs a brothel I like this I agree let's
make it an outdoor brothel and let's
give our girl a job you know what I'm
saying
own your own [ __ ] business man not to
Miguel Miguel bro hasta luego
yeah
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching